[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
personne n'est venu au rendez-vous
déviant le fln s'est refusé à s'y
présenter
les forces de police ont pu multiplier
les patrouilles sans dissimuler pour
cela le vide d'un evian en deuil le
souvenir de son père assassiné
[Musique]
les blocages de l'hôtel du parc reste un
mystère et l'hôtel lui-même et sans voix
evian est aujourd'hui le nom d'un rendez
vous manqué et c'est dans ce climat que
le général de gaulle a voulu exprimer sa
pensée devant 600 journalistes venus du
monde entier
dans le monde actuel et à l'époque où
nous sommes
la france n'a aucun intérêt à maintenir
sous sa loi et sous sa dépendance une
algérie qui choisit un autre destin et
la france n'aurait pas intérêt à porter
à bout de bras
l'existence des populations dans une
algérie qui se dressent devenue
maîtresse d'elle-même et qu'ils
n'offriraient rien en échange de ce
qu'elle aurait a demandé alors on dit
mais ces territoires dans la france se
retire rei tomberont aussi tôt dans la
misère le chaos
en attendant le communisme c'est en
effet sans doute ce qui leur arriverait
mais alors nous n'aurions plus aucun
devoir à leur égard sinon de les
plaindre
pour le moment la france continue à
ramener l'ordre public à accomplir son
oeuvre de progrès à aider l'algérie à
devenir algérienne dans sa structure
après quoi si ce n'est pas en vain le
coeur et la raison de la france
la porteront sans nul doute vers l'est
et vers l'amitié
[Musique]
aux accents de l'hymne de sénégalais
dakar a fêté avec solennité le premier
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la
république du sénégal aux côtés de
léopold senghor président de la
république
les délégués de 72 nations assistaient à
cette manifestation qui constatait la
maturité et la cohésion de la jeune
nation
le chef du gouvernement les chefs d
etats africains d'expression française
monsieur andré malraux représentant la
france
assistaient au défilé qui clôturait ces
journées historiques et où s'unissent et
toutes les forces vives du pays l'armée
les organisations ouvrières et la
jeunesse
à cette occasion dans un discours d'une
belle élévation le président senghor a
convié le sénégal à la construction de
cette civilisation universelle qui
naîtra de toutes les civilisations
particulière
[Musique]
le sénégal entier à participer à ces
réjouissances venus des provinces
éloignées des groupes ont donné le
spectacle de leurs danses ancestrales
sénégal aux multiples aspects les à la
fois enthousiaste et unis c'est aussi
l'indépendance qu'elle célébrait la
foule de dar es salaam capitale du
tanganyka mais une indépendance qui ne
sera effective qu'à la fin de cette
année l'atmosphère toute britannique de
la garden party qui a marqué en haut
lieu l'annnonce de l'événement a
contrasté avec l'exubérance des
réactions populaires affaire de ce type
quant à monsieur julius nyéréré premier
ministre de ce qui était le plus grand
territoire de l'afrique britannique
il a pu dire ce jour est un jour de
triomphe pour le tanganyka mais ce n'est
un triomphe contre personne
[Musique]
oh
nazif t est mauvaise conseillère faute
de buts plus précis à l'heure des
loisirs elle conduit trop facilement
autour d'une table de café ainsi une
certaine jeunesse sans s'en rendre
compte
s'habitue à faire bon ménage avec
l'alcool dont on ne dira jamais assez
qu'il est un fléau national
c'est pourquoi il faut applaudir à des
initiatives telles que celles qui
aboutit à la création à vincennes de la
maison des jeunes et de la culture
ouverte aux jeunes de tous les horizons
qu'ils sortent du collège ou de
l'atelier elle leur offre à travers les
divers clubs de multiples moyens de
meubler leurs loisirs
[Musique]
la maison des jeunes à son restaurant
elle a aussi son bar et garçons et
filles prouve qu'il n'est nullement
nécessaire de s'alcooliser ou de rouler
à 200 à l'heure pour satisfaire à sa
petite fureur de vie il existe
heureusement d'autres chemins pour aller
au devant de la vie
[Musique]
un avion qui a atterri trop vite sur une
piste c'est la catastrophe
non un oeil électronique qui a repéré
l'avion déclenche automatiquement une
barrière d'art pour attraper les
insectes en plein vol il n'existe rien
de mieux que le filet à papillons de
grand papa
les techniciens français de l'armée de
l'air le savent bien ils sont astucieux
et c'est pour cela qu'ils se sont
inspirés de cette méthode pour rattraper
au vol les avions en perdition sur une
piste à l'atterrissage ou à l'école
et voilà le fil est en nylon comme une
paire de bas
il a cependant un avantage sur les bas
c'est marine fils jamais de nombreux
pays étrangers s'intéressent à ce
système
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore un exemple de l'astuce des
techniciens français le parachutisme est
un sport passionnant cependant il n'est
pas à la portée de toutes les bourses
un ingénieur français monsieur le moigne
a trouvé un moyen pour faire du
parachutisme un sport pas cher plus
besoin d'avion ni de torah par htc le
moniteur chef papasoff qui expérimente
le nouveau procédé très simple de
l'ingénieur le moigne le parachute et il
est par un camion après quelques mètres
de course toujours tirée par le camion
le parachutiste célèbre automatiquement
dans le ciel à une centaine de mètres du
sol il retourne ensuite tout
naturellement exactement comme s'il
avait pris son élan d'une tour à
parachute
mais ce n'est pas plus rose
[Musique]
il faut pas que les champions cyclistes
n'ont pas peur du diable puisqu'il sans
quelque 150 au départ de la course paris
roubaix qui passent traditionnellement
paraît-il par l'enfer du nord
nous n'en sommes pas encore là les
mauvaises intentions des organisateurs
sont réservés pour la fin du parcours
[Musique]
malgré quelques escarmouches durant la
première partie de l'épreuve à amiens le
peloton passe très groupée les routes
sont encore bonnes
et puis c'est tellement plus agréable de
se ravitailler en com pas la peine de
courir chacun aura sa musette
quelques-uns ont même une bûche pour
décès
on ne pas trop s'ennuyer on continue de
rouler deux concerts
et puis 20 km de l'arrivée huit hommes
s'échappent par mieux le belge rik van
looy qui règlent tout le monde au sprint
au vélodrome de roubaix
rien de tel pour oublier d'en faire que
le baiser d'un ange
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le château du ministère la maison du
crime
[Musique]
nous sommes chez fantômas ou plutôt chez
le père de fantômas marcel allain qui
avec souvestre voici cinquante ans
écrivit cette série extraordinaire de
lait pouvant en chambre fantôme ainsi
une vie de quarante quatre volumes 44
volume au titre hallucinant aux épisodes
insensé qui cinquante ans après vont
reprendre vie dans une nouvelle édition
[Musique]
quarante quatre volumes bourré de crime
et semer de guillotine qui se rient du
quotidien dafu les conformismes et vont
jusqu'à faire du dandy assassin un
véritable mythe est ce à cause de ces
étranges vertus que fantômas est resté
dans l'esprit des foules et qu'à la
silhouette du lecteur de 1911
correspondent celle du blues au plus ou
moins coloré de l'anneau notre
génération comme celle qui l'attend
c'est reste peut-être anxieuse devoir
passer sur les toits de paris
cette silhouette de mondains et feast of
eli qu être à notre époque pour un tas
de reuver de sensations fortes
cette réincarnation du diable c'est la
question que nous avons posée à marcel
alin rien a tellement changé et ses
fantômes à ce qui vous le dit
[Musique]